the world of visual effects is about to
change forever actually the whole world
is changing right now because machine
learning and artificial intelligence is
revolutionizing how we do things now in
the world of visual effects there's a
triforce of techniques that you have to
apply to almost every shot you'll be
able to separate your shot into layers
aka rotoscoping you need to be able to
fill in those holes that are left behind
when you separate the shots of the
layers aka in painting and then finally
you need to be able to track your camera
so you can replicate that world in the
computer to put new things into the shot
ai has solved potentially two of those
problems and in this video we are going
to do a test to see if that holds true
if it works it's going to change how we
do things at corridor it's going to
change how the industry is doing things
we're going to be able to do projects in
weeks that previously took us months all
right let's go see what i mean
all right guys i got a challenge for you
we're gonna have a race today and the
race is a rotoscope race we have to cut
out clint from this little shot i took
of him dancing trust me it's a very
important shot it's essential that i
have them separated from the background
now i need to figure out the best
technique we have for rose scoping
what's faster so we got doing it by hand
painting style that's griffin we'll take
that over
we have old fashioned basic after
effects masking clint will take that
over
peter here he's got more cutting edge
tools he's going to roller brush 2.0 it
oh matt here always trying to come up
with a curveball he's going to use mocha
and i'm going to use a secret weapon
it's done when there's an explosion
behind you when you're doing your
cartwheel there's an explosion going off
behind you and it looks good and clean
it's done and whoever finishes
rotoscoping the shot first ding your
bell you win a candy bar
may the best roto artist win their
favorite candy bar
so stressful today i'm gonna be
rotoscoping by hand each individual
frame sometimes the traditional way to
do things is the way to go i'm feeling
pretty confident that i'm gonna win this
how many friends in are you um well i'm
almost done with the first frame and uh
let's see how many frames are i don't
think there are too many there's one two
three four
oh
oh
the trick with manual masking manual
rotoscoping is to do it limb by limb i'm
gonna go like as fast as possible i'm
gonna start with my head and then i'll
probably do like my torso you need to
separate your arm from the body
kind of roll through both the arm and
the body at the same time you start with
your keyframe at frame one and you and
you end with a keyframe on frame zero so
no matter what you have the first and
last frame rotoscope anything in between
it starts out real crappy and it gets
better and better and better and better
five and a half minutes guys
what's taking so long huh i will be
doing mocha pro i'm using mocha pro
today um and it has this awesome
magnetic spline tool uh so i can take
his silhouette and it basically sticks
to the edges of him that is my secret
weapon so we'll see we'll see we can do
here dude i'm freaking chilling here
look at look at all these frames i got
so far this i've barely done any work so
i'm going to be rotoscoping with the
after effects beta rotobrush 2. the
original brotobrush was like fine it was
it was a little janky but it worked in
some situations but the second one is
using some kind of ai magic and it's
amazing it works super fast and you
barely have to tweak it the only problem
i'm having is like it's eating up
clint's crotch here do you think sorry
it's eating up clint's crotch
i think i'm gonna i think you know i'm
gonna be right behind nico with his
fancy ai i'm i think i'm going to come
in second here what's going on nico
how's your progress here i mean i'm
pretty much there
it's pretty good whoa
it's pretty dang good six minutes it's
been six minutes so i'm using runway
ml's new green screen tool which is
actually a rotoscoping tool uh it's
actually a site that you access through
your browser and they have this ai model
this machine learning model they trained
specifically for cutting things out you
know i was a little worried like clint
being upside down you know is that going
to throw off things like this
orientation matter to an ai because it
matters to us
you know we look for things to be
oriented a certain way i think i need
more explosion
you know do you have to render it finish
it
are you are you recording right now it's
in my render queue there's no chance for
me then let's see whose renders faster
i need to set up my quicktime settings
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
there's like a ton of artifacting i
totally phoned it in a little bit what
is this don't worry about it what is
that don't worry about it what's all
this background i you know i i was there
and then i heard you picking out your
explosions and i was like i need to just
finish this well hold on i mean you want
to see mine yeah
oh my god that's like
dude
better dumb it's definitely better than
roto brush that's clean
as well because usually with ai you know
you're trading
speed for detail yeah but with this
you're getting both how far did you guys
get i got like a head
dude i got really far i got about
halfway done with my first friend
yeah yeah
you actually feel bad
it's just my torso in my head yeah yeah
i thought you said you're gonna have the
first frame and the last frame for my
torso in my head
i was actually not expecting rotor brush
2 to be as fast as it was it was super
fast a little dirty but still super fast
rotor brush 2 which is ai enhanced and
then runway ml which is even more ai
enhanced i literally had that shot
rotoscoped in 30 seconds and i spent too
much time getting my explosions comp
i got you there if i did have three so
yeah ai is pretty crazy let's just
explore how crazy
[Music]
if there's one thing i hope that you're
already learning from this video it's
that ai is already all around us
especially online and now nothing is
more representative of just how
prevalent ai is and when you can go
online and using a text to image ai
generator generate all kinds of images
so i've got this pulled up here and
courtesy of today's sponsor squarespace
i'm going to be showing you guys exactly
how crazy some of these images can be
let's get started everybody knows that
squarespace has beautiful award-winning
templates so let's start there beautiful
award-winning
templates
hey oh my god a beautiful dog of course
okay squarespace has member areas
meaning that you can create a membership
area for the people that are on your
site to give out exclusive rewards have
a little bit of fun communicate whatever
you want to do with your site that's
your choice hey no judgment from me
let's see what it gives us
what
what is that son it looks like a shark
had its head cut in half while still
obtaining its mouth while eating a diver
guys it's 20 21. and for those of you
who don't know squarespace has
video blocks meaning that you can take
your videos from all over the internet
say you have them on youtube or vimeo or
whatever and put them on your
squarespace site that's right you can
keep videos from all over the internet
on your squarespace okay all right we're
getting into nightmare fuel territory
here we go we've got some sort of lime
green like snake thing that also kind of
looks like a hummingbird it has nothing
to do with video blocks so let's keep
going if there's any image that's almost
guaranteed to give me a great
representation it's going to be this one
now if you don't know multiple
contributors allow small teams of people
to contribute with their respective
strengths to a squarespace website
teamwork makes the dream work
okay
okay it's a it's this
i i feel like there's a lot of
contribution happening in this image and
uh i don't want to be any part of it so
let's move on traffic
overviews meaning that you can see who's
coming to your site which allows you to
create a better experience for your
members users what have you let's give
it a shot
yeah yeah nothing reads cozy and human
like a stop sign that's kind of met with
a an airplane one thing we can be sure
of nothing with ai really gives you that
sense of coziness and and comfort like
you get from a beautiful award-winning
template you can only get that with
squarespace so remember go to
squarespace.com corridor crew to get
started and you'll get 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain you know
you won't have nightmare fuel like this
okay great all right back to the studio
you guys might remember our boss town
dynamics video well that video took us
months and months of work to do
partially because we had to erase clint
from every single shot now this ai is
proving to have some potential for
actually letting us erase things easily
from the frame so now i've done some
tests i'm going to try it on an actual
shot from our old boss town video we
have a shadow to think about and we have
me passing in front of clint we have ram
passing in front of clint so there's a
challenge there so imagine we're gonna
do eight to ten hours of rotoscoping for
just this shot there's just a day of
drawing an outline around a person the
second stage here
is the paint out so to speak where do
you put in behind the gap you've created
now to do this we use basically 3d cards
effectively you track the camera and
then you're basically constantly
freezing and isolating parts of the
background where the characters are not
and you're sliding that into the tracked
shot
to basically fill in that data
so i took all this and i generated a
mask
yeah look at that
so
i'm running this thing called flow
guided video completion on here excuse
me flow guided video completion so it's
going to follow is to follow all the
pixels all the motion of the pixels
which looks really trippy
this is a way to do like the the super
mario effect when you get the star
so the idea is that because it knows
where things are moving it can then
predict what should be in the hole
that's been created by the mask now if
we could remove him automatically using
ai
that would save us
weeks of time on this project well we
already can after effects has content
aware fill
a response just a laugh
i mean we used it on boss town and it
was okay for parts and we definitely had
to
clean up a lot you want to see the
results of my experiment yep
oh wow
oh that's it i'll never see the world
the same way again pretty dang good
though
all right here's here's the challenge
i'm gonna walk in front of him oh it
gets weird
[Music]
yeah because it's thinking it's treating
your pixels as part of the background
right so what i i think i need to do is
when it comes to overlaps i now mask all
of you out you and clinton mast out
there and then you just use the same
roto thing to bring me back in yeah yeah
yeah and that's you know the quirk of
learning this stuff but all the way up
until that point
that's this is totally passable it's
really good
that's yeah thank you thank you now i
think what makes this work is that
there's clean plate like generated as
clint's moving through a shot so we're
going to paint somebody out i think we
need to make sure you start the shot
with people walking into the shot and
then you do the scene or just making
sure the computer at least gets a moment
to see the background without a person
there all right so that's cool and all
right yeah that's pretty cool but you
guys want to just get a little freaked
out by ai so the guys that made the gpt3
thing which basically just lets the
computer write things it gets a little
weird and surreal but the computer just
makes cohesive writing they did it for
pictures and it's insane an illustration
of a baby daikon radish in a tutu
walking a dog this is an ai drawing that
picture but guys let's play with it oh
um shrimp shrimp shrimp shrimp in a tutu
walking a dog
trip in a wizard hat playing a guitar
yeah
look at that there's no way that there's
there's no way there's literally no way
this is possible yo i want a shrimp
with a mustache sipping a latte
animal this is pikachu playing a grand
piano like it did where does this that
is
where does this come from
how does it know what playing
a piano looks like versus just a piano
dude this is probably just the result of
literally looking at billions of images
and i think there's another ai tool that
literally estimates motion capture and
poses from 2d video and so it can see
like you're like this and so all right
so you got like you got your shoulders
you got your spine you got your arms
here and it's not like one to one
accurate it's not nearly as good as like
say an xs or rococo suit we're not there
yet we are quickly approaching that
my biggest takeaway right now is we are
on the precipice of revolutionary new
techniques for visual effects so if you
think back it's like you had the blue
screen revolution where people could cut
things out and put the put new
backgrounds behind them and then boom 3d
animation hits and suddenly cg is big
you can create worlds you can create
characters you can create anything you
can imagine but the next big thing is ai
and visual effects you saw with our luke
skywalker deep fake we'd never touched a
3d model there but we have a total new
character being created what about other
things what about paint out what about
rotoscope what about color correction
what about green screening all these
things that we have to grind through as
vfx artists if suddenly all those
challenges disappear i mean not only is
it huge for the vfx industry and how
it's going to change all the jobs that
are here ideally it's just going to
streamline your creativity you come with
an idea oh i want to have this character
in my shot oh i need to put an explosion
in the background or whatever and then
boom it happens i think a lot of this is
going to happen this year already and
you're seeing us explore it on the
corridor crew channel we are we are
standing on the edge of a giant cliff
and it's not just visual effects it's
everything machine learning is such a
crazy tool
and it's a tool like we're not at the
point where computers are sentient and
they're fighting robot wars yet but this
is literally the cutting edge of
computer technology and you can run it
on you know kind of have to be good
machines but you can run it on a machine
that you can have access to it's gonna
make it so that anybody who wants to go
out and make a film is going going to be
able to do it at the speed of thought
and not at how fast they can click their
mice and tap their keyboards
it's
pretty crazy
and where does the newborn go from here
the net is vast and infinite